[Music]
what conversations do you hope are
generated from this series I think I
think that for me I'm really big on
vulnerability I want people to know that
every every single life is valuable that
their voice can be heard and that there
are people who are willing to be there
for them I'm about to tell you the story
of my life more specifically why my life
ended I know this was based off of a
book are there plans to continue and
after this this season
yeah I mean I think we absolutely could
I think we'd very much like to have that
opportunity you know we're not done with
these characters we really we love them
and I want to know what happens next
those conversations have happened
absolutely talked about what could
happen next the showrunner there might
be a season two of this has that been
talked about I don't know I don't know
honestly I would get in trouble for
saying some things but I hope so I care
so much about this project my mom and I
believe in the message we hope that
people enjoy it do you feel like there's
still more story to tell I definitely
feel like there's more story to tell we
definitely have a lot more dialogue that
we continue for the story we've already
told and I'd love to do it but we'll see
I think that everyone would love to do
another one
if we're given the opportunity because I
think what people see where it leaves
off that there's a I think people are
gonna want to know more about the
characters and what's next for them so I
think there is a possibility so runner
where would you like to see the story go
it's a trip not to give too much away
but I would love to sort of learn more
about who these kids are why they did
what they did and also you know Hannah
made 13 tapes and told us 13 very
specific stories but there's a lot she
didn't tell us and I want to know more
about that I want to know what her
secrets are and the other characters as
well
[Music]
you